[Musica]
il fico digna il fico vigna è un frutto
un frutto rappresentato da una grossa
bacca ricoperta da una pelle e spine è
un frutto che possiamo considerare non
solo così ma sotto tanti altri aspetti
cose che io ho imparato a fare in questi
anni durante la mia attività di ricerca
e ne ho fatto un ingrediente funzionale
che può essere in grado di contrastare
per esempio impiegato come conservante
naturale l'impiego litri e di nitrati
nelle carni l'ho utilizzato come
semilavorato per la strutturazione di
altri formulati alimentari
ne ho utilizzato le bucce per
strutturare dei prodotti da forno e dei
pani funzionali nel mondo sono diffuse
più di 180 specie di fichi d'india
essenzialmente si ritrova nelle zone
aride e semi aride del nostro pianeta
pensate che un feeling in assenza di
acqua può sopravvivere fino a tre anni
in sicilia più di 4.000 ettari della
superficie sono deputati alla
coltivazione del fichi d'india di cui
conosciamo anche diverse aree
particolarmente vocate per la qualità
del frutto stesso che è essenzialmente
distinguiamo in tre diverse culture
differenziando il colore della polpa
quindi conosciamo i fichi d'india polpa
rossa a polpa gialla o arancione a polpa
bianca del fichi d'india però non
dobbiamo distinguere soltanto il colore
della polpa e quindi la cultivar ma
anche l'epoca di raccolta li possiamo
raccogliere come fichi d india gli prima
fioritura e quindi ritrovare nel periodo
che va da luglio ad agosto e quindi sono
conosciuti anche come feeling e di prima
fioritura o agostani possiamo ritrovare
dei frutti che si chiamano di seconda
fioritura
tardivi che amano un periodo di raccolta
che si estende da settembre fino a
novembre quindi con un calendario di
disponibilità abbastanza ampio
proprio i frutti di seconda fioritura
sono quelli che vengono commercializzati
consumati come prodotto fresco che tutti
quanti apprezziamo per la loro succosità
la turgidità della della polpa è che
essendo disponibili anche fino un po
all'autunno inoltrato diventano per noi
anche un ricordo della stagione estiva
però il feeling non è soltanto un fee di
vigna da consumarsi come frutto fresco
ma a diverse qualità importanti diverse
qualità importanti che possono essere
ritrovate essenzialmente nella sua
composizione prevalentemente il 50 per
cento della composizione della siringa è
riscontrabile nella polpa che presenta
diversi nutrienti importanti come un
elevato conduce in carboidrati e in
fibre contiene anche vitamine importanti
per la funzionalità del nostro organismo
contiene anche dei prodotti bioattivi
quindi conosciuti anche come potenti
antiossidanti quali polifenoli
flavonoidi beta segnerebbe tac santin e
gli stessi composti però non si trovano
soltanto nella polpa ma li ritroviamo
anche nella buccia
quindi mi sono chiesta ma the feeling di
prima fioritura che è essenzialmente
vengono scartati essenzialmente sono
consumati a livello locale come prodotto
estivo come frutta e si va associata
spesso ad altri frutti che magari
vengono anche preferiti nello stesso
periodo estivo cosa si può fare come si
può valorizzare questo frutto la mia
prima applicazione con chi sta nella
formulazione che ho chiamato pasta di
figlio vigna è una lavorazione molto
semplice della polpa che però mi
permette di avere
un prodotto con elevata conservabilità
quindi io riesco a dare la colpa di
cinghia fresca per tutto la utilizzabile
tal quale oppure per la preparazione di
altri alimenti gli altri trasformati
presenta un elevatissimo contenuto
quindi conserva anche i composti
antiossidanti tipici del frutto fresco e
quindi è possibile applicarlo in diverse
formulazioni in mano della polpa io
posso anche ottenere un estratto che
anche questo conserva i composti
antiossidanti tipici del frutto e quindi
importantissimi per il nostro benessere
funzionale che ho pensato di incapsulare
quindi di creare delle sfere per poter
consentire un migliore impiego nella
formulazione degli hamburger che sono un
prodotto alimentare altamente deperibile
che oggi riusciamo a conservare ea
ritrovare per esempio nella nello
scaffale dei nostri supermercati grazie
all'impiego di nitriti dietra t che
permettono di mantenere il colore rosso
vivo delle carni perché siano dei
conservanti e allungare quindi la la
vita del prodotto
i nitrati però sono anche imputati oggi
come dei potenziali agenti cancerogeni
quindi è stato per me molto interessante
riuscire a testare come invece un
effetto naturale ottenuto da un frutto
che non è molto utilizzato nelle
trasformazioni e utilizzato solo come
frutto fresco rappresenta per noi anche
un quasi un un frutto di scarto dice con
la scelta può rappresentare invece un
conservante natura quale perché oltre ai
componenti bioattivi che lo
caratterizzano anche una spiccata
attività antimicrobica quindi va a
contrastare la
e crescita della popolazione microbica
che normalmente si avrebbe in un
prodotto fresco come l'hamburger
addizionato di nulla altro ingrediente
che è possibile ottenere dallo scarto
del frutto di prima fioritura e quindi
dalle buccia è una farina che è stata
utilizzata per lo sviluppo di prodotti
da forno
abbiamo sostituito percentuali diverse
di farina nel formulato tradizionale
della nella ricetta tradizionale per
panificazione al mondo da ottimizzare la
quantità necessaria per ottenere cosa un
pane con elevato contenute in fibre
perché l'abruzzo di fichi d'india
presenta un'importante contenuto in
fibre e nel contempo riusciamo a
mantenere e conservare nonostante la
cottura tutti i principi funzionali e
quindi con borse intossicanti già
presenti nella buccia dei cd linee
quindi riusciamo a formulare un alimento
che potrebbe essere definito come
alimento funzionale utilizzando degli
scarti agroindustriali
tutto questo per dire cosa per dire che
il pd d'india e i suoi scarti come anche
altri prodotti ci aiutano ci potrebbero
aiutare oggi a contrastare quelli che
sono i danni sugli alimenti provocati
dai cambiamenti climatici che hanno
provocato e hanno abbassato fortemente
di arese dei prodotti agricoli e quindi
c'è meno cibo per tutti non solo c'è
meno cibo per tutti ma è anche sono
anche degli alimenti che hanno una
minore qualità cioè i nutrienti
importanti per il nostro benessere si
diploma in quantità minoli quindi è
importante andare a capire oggi come per
esempio da scarti agroalimentari o
prodotti o frutti poco utilizzati per il
consumo fresco si possano creare degli
alimenti funzionali che ci permettano di
agevolare quello che sta succedendo
ambientale altri esempi che vorrei
citare sono per esempio l'impiego delle
bucce di pomodoro per la formulazione
sempre di prodotti da forno funzionali
nonchè di frutti di pomodoro non
utilizzati per la trasformazione da cui
possiamo fare per esempio delle chips
che possiamo utilizzare per la merenda
dei nostri figli
oppure ancora una fibra insolubile che
si può estrarre dal passato gli agrumi
che fu diventare un ingrediente un
sostituto dei grassi per la formulazione
di brioche quindi abbiamo da una parte
sostituito un ingrediente calorico e che
in alcuni casi anche per alcuni regimi
alimentari può essere anche dannoso per
il benessere dell'organismo con un uno
scarto agroalimentare che diventa quindi
altrettanto funzionale
vi racconto infine come ciascuno di noi
può fare così per divertimento personale
si è particolarmente addetto alla cucina
può preparare delle cotolette con la
buccia di cheecoting andando a
sostituire semplicemente alla fettina di
carne la buccia ottenuto dal ottenuto
dalla pelatura del del prodotto
[Applauso]
[Musica]